So I got pulled into economics in 2007
because of the 2008 economic crisis.
Mike Brown,
who had been the first cfo of Microsoft,
chief financial officer of Microsoft and
treasure of Microsoft.
He came to Toronto in 2007.
It took my wife and I out to dinner and
said he's trying to put together a
research group to work on economics and
he would like me to be involved.
And I said,
I don't know anything about economics.
He said,
that's okay because nobody does and the
whole system is about to collapse.
He said the the balance sheets of all
the big investment banks,
it's like they have cancer.
They're full of holes.
And I remember being very struck by this
because this is before anybody was
talking about this and so I started to
meet with a group of people that he was
pulling together to understand what was
going to happen and to understand if
there was any way to save the situation.
It was a very ambitious thing and of
course we failed.
But along the way,
I was motivated as a kind of public
service to get interested in economics
and what I found economics in a way it's
very easy for a physicist to understand
because it's very mathematical and the
mathematical models that they use a very
clean.
They're based on assumptions,
hypotheses,
and you can study them.
And then as I started it,
I began to understand some for myself
and more from just reading around
because the false with the standard
economic models with the standard models
of finance are well known.
There had been in the literature for
decades and decades.
So let me give some examples.
The Standard Model of economics is
called the neoclassical model and
assumes that markets are systems where
it's trading happens between consumers
and firms.
And there's certain simple models of how
that goes on and the ideas that these
come to equilibrium equilibrium.
Not In the physical sense,
but especially economic sense in which
you reach a point at which the prices
are fixed,
such that market forces fix the prices
such that you maximize the happiness of
the consumers and maximize the profits
of the firms.
And in so-called equilibrium,
nobody can become happier or more
profitable without somebody else
becoming less happier,
less profitable,
and the ideology behind this,
not behind the mathematics,
because mathematics doesn't have an
ideology,
but behind the arguments that were made
and still are made from this model is
that mark has don't need regulation
because they have these natural
equilibrium where everybody benefits to
the maximum possible.
And if you're in equilibrium,
you can't do better.
Now there's a fault with this,
and it's an obvious follow has been
known since the 19 seventies from some
theorems approved by some economists
including,
um,
some of the founders of this field of
mathematical economics,
which is,
that does not one equilibrium.
There are many equilibria in fact,
is a vast number of equilibria.
And so which equilibria even assuming
that this is a decent model of the
economy,
the economy,
which is not clear,
but even assuming it's a good mile,
which equilibrium you're in depends on
the past history,
depends on regulation,
depends on politics,
depends on taste,
depends on changing tastes,
changing preferences.
And so history matters.
And what's called path dependence
matters.
This takes us outside of the
neoclassical model of economics,
but it doesn't take us outside of
economics because some wiser economist,
for example,
Brian Arthur had for years been
developing models and theories of path
dependent economy with a history does
matter.
People from the area of complex systems
like Stu Koufman and provocative and
developing models of markets where the
history matters,
where there's not a single equilibrium
where there many equilibria and we're
change is paramount,
and another symptom of this is is the
idea that arbitrage isn't.
I mean in these neoclassical models,
when you go to equilibrium,
arbitrage is impossible.
Arbitrize and making a profit from
trading around a circle goods or a
circle of currencies without actually
producing anything and in equilibrium
that's supposed to be impossible,
but lots of firms and investment banks
and made fortunes off of currency
trading.
So why is that?
Turns out because you never really at
equilibrium.
So why is the notion of equilibrium so
powerful?
I think part of the answer is this idea
of physics envy that economists thought
that what they were doing was more
scientific,
has more corrected.
It looked like physics and physics had
this timeless picture in which we're
really mattered as we were saying
before,
is the whole history of the system and
in physics there's also a big notion of
coming to equilibrium,
which is though however it's important
to say as a different notion of
equilibrium and somehow people in
economics got seduced into this model,
which again works in the small.
If you have a small little corner of the
economy,
a small market,
it may work for awhile to characterize
approximately what's going on.
Arbitrage is not always there.
It's not always.
I mean I recharge.
Opportunities do get eaten up the market
forces which do push you towards
equilibria.
There is some truth in it,
but the whole thing is a disaster.
If I can say that as an outsider and it
led indirectly.
It wasn't the only reason why
regulations were lifted on markets and
trading through the decades,
but when people were making arguments to
Congress,
to the president's office there that
would be that the economy would be
better off without regulation.
This was the quote,
scientific rationale for it and led to
the very unstable situation of the last
economic crisis and still a very
dangerous and unstable situation in the
world economy because,
well,
I'm not an economist.
I'm not going to pontificate about the
problems in the economy,
but one could see
how the idea of timelessness gave false
comfort to an unsuccessful scientific
theory in the realm of economists of
economics.